welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show number eight five five two three
six thirty two twenty eight that is
eight five five two three six thirty two
twenty eight Kyle in Minnesota you're on
the bench Shapiro she'll go for Kyle my
question was about Roe vs. Wade I was
wondering do you think it's likely
that'll be overturned like any time in
the near future extraordinarily unlikely
I really do not think that you have even
four votes for overturning Roe vs. Wade
I doubt that justice Cavanaugh is
interested in overturning Roe vs. Wade I
don't think the Justice Roberts
think that the most likely scenario is
the gradual chipping away at Planned
Parenthood versus Casey so Roe versus
Wade suggests that the that abortion
must be allowed up until point of
viability the Planned Parenthood versus
Casey test sort of changed the standard
of row that the Planned Parenthood
versus Casey test basically suggests
that there can't be undue burden on the
woman that's a vaguer test and you've
seen courts in the past sort of chip
away at that obviously the the Supreme
Court has allowed federal bans on
partial-birth abortion saying that's not
an undue burden on women you've seen
various other forms of legislation
ranging from that abortion clinics have
to be licensed to admit at local
hospitals to time-based restrictions
admitted by the Supreme Court we're
gonna find out in very short order
whether the Supreme Court is okay with
allowing Louisiana to force abortion
clinics to have registration ability at
local available hospitals that's the
most likely scenario is that the the
states gradually peel back kind of layer
by layer allowances for abortion but I
think that the idea of Roe versus Wade
being overturned by the Supreme Court on
mass it's very very unlikely I do not
think that you have votes for that I
think you have three I don't think you
have five and I think that that is one
of the grave challenges that Republicans
are constantly engaging in is that
Republicans don't play the same game as
Democrats Democrats who openly say we
will not nominate anyone to the Supreme
Court unless they uphold Roe versus Wade
Republicans won't even ask the question
of their own nominees and I think that's
ridiculous in disastrous I think that
the Republicans certainly should be
asking their own nominees where do you
stand on Roe versus Wade fire president
I wouldn't nominate anybody unless I
believe they would overturn Roe vs. Wade
as a matter of law forget about where I
stand on abortion as a matter of law Roe
versus Wade is an abomination and has
nothing to do with the Constitution and
it doesn't even pretend
to have anything to do with the
Constitution of the United States Kyle
okay thank you I'll really appreciate
the call Andrew in San Diego California
you're on the bench Peter struggle hard
Andrew I've been I think in the past
couple of months our sincere eyes and
grateful fall Bernie Sanders the word
socialism communism and democratic
socialism are getting thrown around
around a lot and I was hoping you could
define those terms for everyone and then
secondly I'm a huge Star Wars fan I love
the prequels episode three is my
favorite I know you probably despise
that I said that but if you could only
watch either the prequels or the sequels
for the rest of your life which of the
two trilogies would you choose okay well
I'll start with the second question
because it's easier obviously the
prequels are better than the sequels
there's no question I mean my kids are
very into the prequels right now
actually Attack of the Clones is
shockingly not as bad as I thought it
was when I first watched it Phantom
Menace is a disaster I mean Phantom
Menace is just horrible except for the
duel at the very end and Revenge of the
Sith I recently rear ank my Star Wars
choices and I believe I put revenge of
this at third it may have been fourth
after rogue one so revenge of the Sith
actually has some pretty effective
moments everything with Palpatine is
really effective in a range of the Sith
so I will take the prequels over the
sequels at least the prequels didn't
kill my favorite characters in the worst
and stupidest possible way as far as the
differences between socialism and
communism do not buy into the Bernie
Sanders line that socialism is like
Norway and Denmark and the communism is
the Soviet Union that is nonsense
socialism is just a broader rubric that
includes communism the the social
democracy is not the same thing as
Democratic Socialist Bernie is basically
fussing up his terms because he wishes
to proclaim himself a Norway Denmark guy
which would just mean sort of the modern
Democratic Party honestly in reality
he's backed every communist regime that
he can that he can lay his eyes on so
that there really is no difference
between socialism and communism
socialism definitionally means the
communal ownership of the means of
production okay and there's no way to do
that in the absence of state compulsion
which means communism right there is no
other way to do that because once the
society owns the means of production
they're going to end distributes from
each according to his ability to each
according to his need that's communism
so the only question is whether the
basis of the society is free and
capitalistic as it actually is in Norway
Sweden Denmark Switzerland or whether
the basis of the society lies in the
collective ownership of the means of
production as it does in Venezuela or
the Soviet Union or Cuba bernie is
definitionally in favor of socialism not
social democracy he just lies about
dandruff yeah thanks man I just I
couldn't I see the terms Cummings and
socialism a lot and they just seem like
the same thing to me I couldn't
differentiate oh that's right just lie
about it it's one of those annoying
things in politics is when people
redefine terms to their own benefit is
when they suggest what socialism really
means is just that you have a social
safety net in a highly capitalistic
society that is absolute nonsense and
there's a reason that that Bernie does
it there's reason aoc does it because
when anybody looks communism directly in
the face it looks a lot more like China
and a lot less like Sweden or Denmark KC
and Michigan you're on the bench Bureau
should go for KC good on your
ever-expanding family I appreciate it
thanks so much Casey yeah you know I got
a question on constitutional law and
then corporate law do you have time I'm
a big person that's into equal
application of the law and I got to
believe our four founders had checks and
balances for a reason but also political
places to be paid the Constitution
states about nullification and
impeachment where the term should be
gotten back I mean President Trump I
think has a really good case for suing
to get his term back I know the 22nd
amendment was never really challenged
but I think he's got a good case because
ultimately the electorate's would be the
one choosing the the president but it's
not if you've got a partisan Congress
and I don't think they ever imagined
after passing the 22nd amendment that it
would be used as such a political tool
so I think the price needs to be paid by
giving any impeached president that turn
back because he was kneecap he was damn
strong yeah
okay Casey I think that legally speaking
there there's not a lot there legally
speaking you're never gonna be able to
sue to get a turn back impeachment is a
constitutional remedy even if it is
completely misused by the Democrats is I
think that it was in this case obviously
President Trump politically is gonna
make a lot of hay out of the impeachment
effort he's gonna point out that the
Democrats didn't even charge him with a
crime when they tried to impeach him
that they are partisan hacks and all of
that is true Casey but the idea that the
22nd amendment which limits people to
two terms in office is going to be
revoked on a legal basis or Trump
conservator term I don't see that
happening Casey I really appreciate the
call Richard and you ty you're on the
bench P oh sure go for it Richard hey
Ben I haven't been following politics
tell apparently recently but I've
noticed that there's been a lot of hate
towards Mitt Romney about wanting him to
resign and all I've asked about it so a
few other people and all they told me
was he's Republican in name only and I
understand that he voted against Trump
during his impeachment so I was
wondering if he could have put a little
more light on that for me yeah I mean
obviously Mitt Romney is conservative I
mean he votes with president from 95% of
the time literally 95 percent of the
times when people say that he's not
conservative what they really mean is
that Romney says mean things about
President Trump that he doesn't like
Trump Trump doesn't like him that he
voted in favor of one charge of
impeachment on the abuse of power
charge yeah the notion that Romney is
not conservative or that he's a bad
conservative I don't see that like I
think there was a case to be made that
he wasn't conservative enough when he
was governor of Massachusetts right he
did pass Romney care he did blow out the
spending in the state of Massachusetts
but the notion that he's not been
conservative his Utah senator because
he's at odds with President Trump over
over Trump's activities on Ukraine I
don't buy that I don't I don't make I
don't make support of Trump's rhetoric
or support of particular Trump actions
that have nothing to do with the
conservative agenda a litmus test for
conservatism but Romney I said this at
the time he is a he's an a senator with
his own independent judgment he gets to
make that judgment I think his judgment
on impeachment was dead wrong I don't
think he should be thrown out of office
for that I think it's kind of ridiculous
when people suggest you should be thrown
out of office for that Richard I thank
you thank you back I
really appreciated thanks for the call
wearing it two more of your calls today
five five two three 6:30 teach ones yet
on pandemic today because the w-h-o has
declared coronavirus a global pandemic
we'll get some more of that in a bit
we'll give you some updates but Samuel
in British Columbia Canada you're on ben
shapiro struggle for example hey Dan
how's it going I'm a huge fan I've
watched your show for five years and I
just like the first day that you've had
a huge impact on me and Who I am and
what I prioritize as a person I really
appreciate it means a lot to me anyway
go for it yeah so anyways my family is a
conservative family but most of us are
kind of split on the issue of gun
control so my question is why would
somebody need to possess anything other
than a pistol to protect themselves well
the answer is actually a pistol was not
necessarily the best form protecting
yourself like I have a shotgun for home
protection Samuel a lot of people use a
ours for for home protection because
rifles are very accurate I use a shotgun
and that has slugs that don't penetrate
the walls which actually is kind of
important shotguns are also good because
when you rack a shotgun and freaks
people out and so I might make them run
so you never have to fire the weapon in
the first place also if you're talking
about guns that are likely to be used in
murders pistols are far more likely to
be used in murders than rifles are it's
very weird that there's so much focus on
long guns when the reality is that
pistols are used in like exponentially
more murders in the United States then
long guns are because they're easier to
carry they're easier to transport that
are easier to hide and and all the rest
of it so that as far as automatic
weapons full-on machine guns have been
banned in the United States for
distribution for mass distribution since
1934 so it's just not the case that
Americans are walking around on mass
carrying machine guns capable of firing
off 100 rounds at a time now that said
you can obviously you could obviously
alter the weapon but that's illegal
anyway so laws are not going to change
somebody who is breaking the law Samuel
so the question really isn't why
Americans should have particular types
of guns the question is why the
government should have the right to take
away a particular type of gun and the
first answer should be that it's
inherently more dangerous than other
types of guns this is not true of an
ar-15
it is true maybe of a well probably
certainly it's true of like a full-on
automatic machine gun which is why even
the NR
ray is not stumping for the repeal of
the National Firearms Act 1934 okay well
anyways thank you so much for answering
my question I appreciate the question
and thanks for listening to the show
Samuel all right we'll get some more of
your questions at 8:55 at two three six
thirty two twenty eight in just a moment
first coming up we're gonna take more of
your phone calls at eight five five two
three six thirty two twenty eight that's
eight five five two three six thirty two
twenty eight this is the bench bureau
show